and chris bassett as he would make in
his 20th start 10 wins on the season so
he has just done an outstanding job for
the athletics and of course probably a
lot of fans in the
friends family watching him back in the
mid
cleveland area we're ready to go bradley
zimmer steps in
first ball hit high in the air deep
right center field goodbye
bradley zimmer on the first pitch of the
game
rocks it out of here and the indians
take a one-nothing lead
his second home run of the year both
coming in this series
are you kidding me that's a shot in the
arm right there baby right down the
middle he wants to get strike one
and zimmer hits his second home run in
the series and
wow to lead off a game something special
he's back home where he went to school
to don zach pleisek will tow the rubber
for the indians he's our northeast ohio
ford dealer starting pitcher please sack
making his second start since coming off
the il
you see his record as a four and three
last three road starts he's three and oh
chop to third jose ramirez on the run
makes a high throw in bradley
great reaction to go up and get it and
then slap the tag down on canna for
route number one yeah he had time to
come down and put the tag on him very
nice
he just tries to make the throw on the
run and gets underneath it a little bit
but
there's bobby catches it comes down
tagged him right on the back
got him and kenna never even touched the
bag afterwards anyway
watch him he went right over it
owen won the count on bradley who's
looking for his first hit in the series
yeah well you know what you're going to
make mistakes there you go i like that
stroke
bobby bobby he shoots one the other way
his first hit of the series
in which he's going six for 20 with
three home runs
and he bunts bare hand attempt by
chapman
comes up empty and the indians have
their first two aboard
this one tapped out in front murphy
picks it up spins
fires in time and basic gets out of the
jam
so indians had two on and nobody out and
they
do not score bottom of the second coming
up
268 11 homers 45 rbis he's hitting seven
of his last eight during that time he's
13 for 30.
387. smokes one to right
johnson hustling over not going to get
it he bangs off the wall
johnson with a good arm gets it back in
quickly a long single for lowry
and then the 3-0 pitch outside he walked
in two on nobody out for the ace here in
the second
two on and nobody out here is chapman
grounded to clement clement coming
across the back
throws it low bradley can't dig it out
lowry's going to come in and score
i mean it was taylormade flipped there
but west clement just
you know why why make that kind of a
play why not just come across
plant and make a strong throw knowing
basically you make a bad throw a run's
going to score he threw that sidearm
here's his pitch swung on line to right
johnson giving it a run he reaches and
makes the catch as he goes
tumbling to the ground heading toward
the line
great play by daniel johnson to stave
off the rally by the athletics who do
score one run
pass it reaches back and grabs it spins
around and throws to olson for the
second half
defend yourself if you can and become an
athlete
at a baby sea bass there's outs to be
had out there don't be afraid to get
involved in the party if you're the
starting pitcher if you're a pitcher in
general
feel free to come up off that now and
make a move
bradley zimmer homer to lead off the
game fly to center his last time up
he lines a fastball into center field
jack johnson around third he will score
easily
and it's 2-1 cleveland as bradley zimmer
has knocked him both in today
zimmer said no way he got this one it
got down on the trademark he didn't hit
it great but he fell in
got some outfield grass with two outs
he's off and running
the indians retake the lead zimmer has
both rbis
yeah got that one up yeah he did and
zimmer able to cut her off no gets by
him
laureato in the second base with a lead
off double
throw goes awry but backed up smartly
now loriana's gone for third they got
him
oh baby they got him jose ramirez
with a heads up defensive play to come
back and get loriano
who pushed all his chips into the center
of the table he
gambled and he lost you know that
hesitation
cost him he wanted to pick it up see
police act coming into play
i think they got him and he's gone
now the 2-2 pitch to seth brown is swung
on a deep drive to right
way back johnson at the track he will
turn and watch it
fly
and seth brown has tied it up
that's his 11th home run is to
indians too in the bottom of the fifth
you got big mo knocking on the other
side little change up just gonna flutter
up in the strike zone
seth brown got the foot down past the
box you know where
[Music]
daniel johnson the batter he's had a
good day
great catching right one for two at the
plate he scored a run
here's the pitch swung on and there's a
high fly ball
that's hit to deep center way back home
run
johnson and the indians are
back in front
3-2 tribe and the big day
for daniel johnson close to home
continues
his first major league home run
and it comes at the oakland coliseum
the ballpark he grew up watching major
league baseball in
and caught it in the air
watch your lips gun slinger
jake dietman right now i promise you
internally is checking
all of his body parts making sure
everything's intact
all in one piece this is purely
reactionary
so here's the matchup with the bases
loaded perez
against romo
and he did so perez strikes out
romo does his job he's pumped up as
always
[Music]
[Applause]
right field coming around third is
mercado here's the throw to the plate
cut off
bradley zimmers having a day his third
hit
his third run batted in and it's 4-2
cleveland
the indians go to oakland and win a
series for the first time
since 2014. they take two out of three
and they win it today by a final of four
to two
[Applause]
great pitching the story zach please
sack nick wittgen phil maton
brian shaw pulled the oakland a's to two
runs on
four hits here this afternoon